les vaches du salon de l'agriculture en
raffole le point fabrique et à la ferme
de viltain à jouy en josas un produit à
base de graines de tiges et de feuilles
de maïs
réalisé à partir de la récolte de
l'année dernière 5 tonnes sont livrés
chaque jour sur le salon de
l'agriculture
et y'a rien à dire les vaches il est il
est froid il ap temps il est il reste
une matière sèche correct pour la base
d'idées il faut que ce soit consommé
frais donc on peut pas aller et venir
chercher sa du centre de la france
comme on est la ferme la plus près de
paris bien ils sont très contents et
nous on cultive plus de maïs parce qu'on
sait qu'on va avoir 300 vaches au salon
à nourrir pendant une semaine en plus de
nourrir les bêtes la ferme de viltain
est présente depuis trente ans sur le
salon à son stand activités pédagogiques
et dégustation attire de nombreux
visiteurs
c'est vraiment un grand moyen à prendre
surtout le domaine des animaux ce qu'ils
mangent
elle peut toucher même si c'est interdit
elle peut toucher donc c'est très
agréable
on a fait beaucoup de jeu
on a fait beaucoup de dégustation qui on
a vu des animaux c'est l'occasion pour
nous de 20 de rencontrer des clients des
clients de
qui achète peut-être toute l'année nos
produits qui ont l'occasion de les
manger aussi dans leur restaurant
d'entreprise
et qui sont content de le retrouver ici
et du coup qui voit vraiment
l'agriculteur c'est l'occasion de leur
dire vous pouvez venir à la ferme une
ferme pas très loin de paris né à 17km
venait de rencontrer ni voir la traite
des vaches à partir du lait de ses
vaches l'exploitation de jouy en josas
fabrique ses yaourts et d'autres
produits laitiers on a mis dans le fonds
de la confiture et par dessus du yaourt
légèrement sucrées quand on mélange les
bains ont fait soi même
manger un petit peu dire que natura
promet un peu plus de confiture etc
c'est un peu ludique confiture de lait
c'est du lait du sucre cuit ensemble
pendant
quatre heures avec de l'avenir
le laisse se réduisent caramélise
devient marron et ça fait une batte à
tartiner pour cette édition 2010 est la
ferme de viltain reçu une médaille
d'argent et deux médailles de bronze
pour trois de ses yaourts